Президентський законопроект про реінтеграцію Донбасу
пройшов перше читання ще у жовтні.
Але ухвалити його не можуть дотепер.
Що він передбачає і про що не можуть домовитись депутати?
Законопроект передбачає відмову від статусу Антитерористична операція.
Дії України на Донбасі визначаются у законопроекті як стримування та відсіч збройної агресії.
При цьому Росія визнається державою-агресоркою,
а непідконтрольні Києву райони Донецької та Луганської областей -
тимчасово окупованими.
Ця окупація називається нелегітимною і такою,
що не надає РФ жодних територіальних прав.
Так само не визнається чинність документів, виданих так званими "ДНР" та "ЛНР".
Закон, на думку депутатів, посилить позицію України на дипломатичному рівні
та створить передумови для перемоги у міжнародних судах проти Росії.
Згідно із законопроектом, за громадянами України,
які внаслідок бойових дій були змушені полишити свої домівки і переїхали,
зберігається право власності на майно і нерухомість на окупованих територіях.
Крім того, у документі наголошується, що Київ не несе відповідальності
за порушення прав мешканців тимчасово окупованих територій.
Хоча і збиратиме інформацію про усі злочини проти громадян,
аби притягти Росію до відповідальності.
Попри те, що законопроект стосується окупованої частини Донбасу,
згадали у ньому і про Крим.
До другого читання в документ включили дату початку окупації української території
- 20 лютого 2014 року  та додали положення
про зобов'язання Росії повністю забезпечувати окуповані території.
Ухвалити законопроект про реінтеграцію Донбасу депутати намагаються вже понад півроку.
Розгляд документу відкладають, адже не можуть дійти згоди щодо кількох ключових питань,
кажуть у Блоці Порошенка.
Зокрема, йдеться про визнання Росії агресором,
за що вже проголосували у першому читанні, та згадування Мінських домовленостей,
посилання на які прибрали ще до першого голосування.
Серед інших пояснень затримки із голосуванням -  ризик зриву обміну полоненими,
який мав відбутися цього року.
Адже сепаратисти можуть відмовитися обміняти заручників,
якщо Росію в Україні офіційно назвуть країною-агресором.